ASTRO TELLER: About
five years ago,
right as Google X
was being birthed,
I sat down with Larry Page.
And I was trying to work
with him on how we were going
to talk about what Google X is.
And I was having a hard time
getting something concise out
of him.
So I just started throwing
things at him to respond to.
So I said, are we
a research center?
He said, "no."
I'm glad to hear that.
Are we an incubator?
"Sort of, not really."
Are we just another
business unit for Google?
Is that what we're going to be?
"No."
The original vision statement
that Kennedy gave to the nation
in 1961, that we were going
to put a man on the moon
and return him safely by
the end of the decade,
was the original
moonshot proposal,
at least in the moonshot sense.
So I was delighted when I--
after 10 of these things,
I threw out to Larry,
are we taking moonshots?
And he said, "yes,
that's what we're doing."
That made me really happy.
So from that afternoon
on, what I've
been telling the
people at Google X
is that we're trying to
build a moonshot factory.
What I mean by that is that
we're trying to take moonshots.
That word is to
remind us that we're
trying to work on things that
are very hard, that aspire
to make the world 10
times better in some way
than it currently
is, not 10% better,
to remind us about the
risks that we're taking
and the long-term nature of the
work that we have ahead of us
when we try to do these things.
The word factory is
meant to remind us
that even though we are doing
these risky long term things,
that we want to pursue
doing them with an eye
to actually having the
impact that we aspire to,
that we're building products
and services for the real world.
Fast forward five years,
I'm tickled, I confess,
to see that the
word moonshot has
made its way, fairly heavily
now, into the popular lexicon.
I understand though-- I
haven't seen the show myself--
that the TV show, "Silicon
Valley," the Google in it
is called Hooli.
And they've now started their
own Google X-like organization,
which they call XYZ, instead.
And it's taking moonshots also.
And I've personally
been upgraded
from captain of moonshots to
head daydreamer in the TV show,
apparently.
The fact that it's out
there is important.
And part of the reason that
I think that it's important
is that there's this
bizarre-- it's understandable,
but it's this frustrating
game of "Not It"
that we all play with ourselves.
So the small companies say,
I can't take moonshots.
That's for big companies to do
because it costs a lot of money
to take moonshots.
The big companies
say, well, we aren't
going to take
moonshots because that
means taking a lot of risk.
That's not really our game.
That's what the small companies
should do because they
have nothing to lose.
The governments say, well,
you know like 50 years ago,
we were taking moonshots.
But that's not really
our thing anymore.
We have to work on popular,
immediate problems.
We don't have any money.
Like, that just
can't be us, sorry.
Academics love talking
about moonshots.
They like writing the papers.
They actually produce some of
the underlying science that,
later, can turn into a
moonshot, but they're not
the system builders
who are going to build
the moonshot themselves.
Everyone thinks it's
someone else's job.
But we're not going to fix the
biggest problems in the world
if everyone thinks it's
someone else's job.
The truth is, we can
all work on moonshots.
Working on things that aspire
to be 10 times better, rather
than 10% better, is a mindset.
That's what it is.
It's got nothing
to do specifically
with the risk, or the
money, or the time frame.
It's a mindset about what
we're working towards.
And counterintuitive
as it is, if you
work on things that aspire
to be that much better,
it not only isn't
harder, sometimes
it's literally
easier because, when
you aspire to make the
world that much better,
you have to start over.
And when you've acknowledged
to yourself as a team
that you're going
to start over, you
know that what's
going to happen next
can't be built on what
people have done before.
You have to, in a
meaningful sense,
come at it from a
new perspective.
And that often, not
always, but often unlocks
possibilities that make the
impossible seem possible.
So this is our
blueprint for how we
take moonshots, for
what a moonshot should
be in our minds.
The first thing
is that there has
to be a huge problem in the
world that we want to resolve,
that we want to have
go away or mitigate
in some meaningful way.
So for example,
1.2 million people
die every year in car accidents.
More than a trillion
dollars is wasted every year
with people sitting in traffic.
That is a legitimately
world scale
problem it would be awesome
if we could make go away.
Number two, there has to be
a radical proposal for how
to make that problem go away.
If it's something that people
have tried over and over before
in the past, the idea that
we or you or anyone else
by just trying harder, or
staying up later at night
is not really a good outcome.
It's not very likely to work.
So cars that drive themselves
all the way from point A
to point B-- I think
that's like the poster
child for a radical
sounding proposal
to make that kind
of problem go away.
And then, the third
one is there has
to be some reason to
believe some breakthrough
technology, some aha from
science or engineering,
which makes us believe that,
even if it's not guaranteed
to work, we have a decent shot
at learning through the process
and maybe, just
maybe, getting there.
In the case of
self-driving cars,
that was the DARPA
Grand Challenge
work that originally
happened and some advances
in smart software
and smart sensors.
So each project that
fits into this mold then
has to describe not just
that it fits these things,
but that, in
principle at least, it
could produce in the long
run a Google scale business
or Google scale value to
the company in order for us
to help it move forward.
Our goal is to have
each of these things
create a ton of
value for the world,
but then also create
back to Google
a fair or equitable
return on its investment
for taking these big risks.
And five years in,
I'm very happy to say
that we've started to make
real progress in this space
through the graduations
that we've done.
Some of them play out
in different ways.
So for example, the massive
neural network project
that we originally
built at Google X,
we graduated back into
the main part of Google,
called knowledge, which is what
you might think of as search.
And in that part
of Google, it now
is servicing over 50
products and services helping
all these different parts
of Google turn signals
into symbols more
effectively, which is helping
Google to be successful.
And certainly, that's
not all our credit
because they've done
a lot since they left.
But we helped to get that going.
And that is a good example
of the sort of thing
that we're shooting for.
In a very different way,
the smart contact lens
work that we built,
it wasn't going
to probably work out
optimally for us,
not only to do the original
work on that project,
but to take it all the way
to the market ourselves.
So we developed a partnership
with Alcon, the eye care
division of Novartis, and now
we are headed towards the market
through this still
very complex process
of trying to make
contact lenses be
able to sense the glucose in
your eye to help diabetics
manage their diabetes better.
But that is another
example where
value can be released through
this work, in this case,
through a partner.
Another of the critical
operating principles
that we have at Google X
is throwing ourselves out
into the world to get
contact with the real world
as fast as possible.
It's not sometimes a
natural thing to do,
but it is an absolute
critical thing
to do, especially when
you're taking on particularly
big, hard projects.
You can't possibly know at
beginning the right thing
to do, but you can
have a process where
you discover faster, rather
than slower, that you're
on the wrong track.
That, you can do.
So we go through these
processes for things
like the self-driving cars,
for our flying wind turbines,
for Project Loon, for
contact lens work that we do,
and for others.
We go through this process
where we force ourselves
to seek out this contact.
And sometimes, this turns out to
be us dragging our balloons up
to South Dakota to expose
the balloons to Arctic winds.
Sometimes, it's asking a
really specific tiny question,
like how long will
this glucose sensor
the size of a piece
of glitter actually
be able to sense glucose while
sitting in this tear fluid.
The question is how
and how fast can you
discover that what
you're working on
is the wrong thing
to be working on.
And the secret is
it's discouraging
to hear these things.
We all avoid going
out into the world,
throwing ourselves at the
world to discover these things.
But no matter how
discouraging it
is now, if you put more
time into doing it,
you will unconsciously avoid
even more doing it tomorrow,
or a week from now,
or a month from now.
And that's why doing
it as fast as you can
is actually the easiest time
and the most efficient time
to discover that you're
on the wrong path.
And that's why it is sort of
central to how Google X works
on solving these problems.
I want to emphasize--
what this basically
means is we don't know.
And I would go so far
so to say, nobody really
knows the right way to
build any of these projects.
If you listen to
the media stories,
you get this nice, tight arc
where the entrepreneurs that
make it were
destined to make it,
and the ones that didn't work
were losers who were never
going to make it anyway.
And it completely
misses the point,
that feeling in the
pit of your stomach
where you know where
you want to get to,
but you really don't
know how to get there.
I have those feelings
all the time.
Every single one of our
project leads at Google X
has those feelings.
You're not alone.
That's just the
truth of the world
that we have those
feelings all the time.
All we can do is take
our best guess about what
we should be building.
And then, don't wait.
Get quickly out into
the world to discover
how wrong you are, which
parts are salvageable,
and which parts
you need to go back
to the drawing board about.
That's the only way
to race forward.
So I'm going to tell
you about Project
Wing as an example of this.
Project Wing had some
kind of bumpy months--
some very bumpy months
in late 2013, early 2014.
So the goal for Project
Wing is self-flying vehicles
for delivery.
That huge problem with the
world that we aspire to,
we believe that there are
still a significant amount
of friction in how physical
things are moved around
in the physical world.
And if you look, historically,
at the Pony Express
and the introduction
of the post office,
at mail order catalogs--
which are kind of weirdly
the precursor to ecommerce
on the internet-- If you look
at boats, planes, trains, every
time people have introduced
a way to more efficiently
move physical things around
in the world, it has utterly and
positively changed the world.
There's lots of friction left,
let's remove some more of it.
But that's too hard to work
on, to get your arms around
at the beginning.
It's just too much.
So we had to pick
something to start with.
There was a process
of brainstorming.
And the thing that we got
excited about at the beginning
was to deliver
defibrillators to people.
So if somebody is having a
heart attack-- you've probably
seen like an ER show,
they say, clear.
And they hit their chest.
And the guy wakes
up again, hopefully.
So there is in this
building, I guarantee you,
like five AEDSes, Automatic
External Defibrillators.
I bet you not a single person
in this room knows where it is.
And if somebody fell down
on the floor right now,
I doubt you anyone would find
it in the next 5 to 10 minutes,
sadly.
What if defibrillators
could come
find you-- at least get to
the front of the building,
maybe even get all the way
to the person who needed it.
So this was our vision.
It's small.
And it's something
where time matters.
It's about eight to nine
minutes from when someone
has a heart attack
to when they actually
get help, today on average.
If we could shave four
minutes off of that time,
we would save 20,000 lives
a year just in the US.
So the team got really
excited about this.
That's a mission.
That's a great beachhead
mission for this bigger goal.
So we started two
things in parallel.
The engineers, all
psyched up because they
were going to save
all these lives,
started building a first
version, or a vehicle,
which by the way--
this turns out
not to be the right vehicle.
Story for another day.
But that was another
failure mode that we had.
And we're now doing a
very different vehicle.
That was a painful
moment for the engineers.
But while they were building
the hardware, the software,
the sensors for these
vehicles, we also immediately
had a real world team
that went out to ask,
can we kill this project
right now, or at least
that direction for the project,
by finding out that there was
something wrong with the plan.
We went out and we
talked to people,
actually had them,
on dummies, use
these automatic
external defibrillators.
We went and we talked to the
emergency response people
in communities.
We literally sat and watched
them take phone calls
and talk to the person who ran
the 911 center in various towns
and said, well, could we
plug into what you're doing.
And we quickly found
out the whole plan
wasn't going to work.
That's good though.
I promise you, this was
enormously depressing
for the team, but it was only
going to be depressing for them
in a much bigger
way if we'd let them
go for another year and a
half til they were all done,
and then, discovered that it
was the wrong thing to do.
That would have been much more
expensive, much more painful.
It turned out that it
wasn't the right thing
to do because number
one, the defibrillators
are quite hard to use.
In principle, they're
not, but most people
don't apply them really well.
So if you get someone
something they
don't know how to
use really quickly,
you actually haven't
made the world
as better as you were hoping.
And the other one is that
911 is just not set up
to let us start flying
to where the call came
from the moment
they get the call.
In fact, you would be surprised
how much they don't even
understand where
the call comes from.
It's a somewhat
antiquated system.
So it just wasn't a good plan,
and this was really depressing
for the team.
The team took a big step back.
Initially, we were
trying to figure out what
a better beachhead would be.
And we came to what I
think was the right answer.
This is about 9, 10
months ago where we said,
you know what, we're not
going to pick a beachhead.
Instead, let's just throw
ourselves into the world.
And we went to Australia and
we started doing deliveries.
And we discovered
things in that process.
We discovered a ton of
But among other
things, we discovered
things people wanted delivered
that we hadn't even imagined.
Cattle ranchers
were saying to us,
do you know what would
be awesome is vaccines.
We're out in the field.
The vaccines have to be
stored in a refrigerator,
so we never have them with us.
They have a really
poor shelf life,
so we often don't even
have them in our barns.
But you want it like right
there, that's when you need it.
If something could just come
in the middle of the field
and hand me the vaccine, that
would be amazing for the cows
that they're taking care of.
We would never have
figured that out sitting
in a conference room on a
whiteboard, I promise you.
So Project Loon.
The goal for Project
Loon is to beam internet
down to the four billion
people in the world who
do not currently have
a good connection
to the digital world.
Four billion people.
It's sort of hard to imagine
something more worth working on
than that.
And most of these people,
surprisingly by the way,
already have the device.
More than half of them
already have a device.
It's actually the absence of the
connection to the digital world
which is stymieing their ability
to participate in modern life
and to get access to better
health outcomes, literacy,
the ability to vote,
lots of other things.
So when we started
because the idea was
to do this from
stratospherically
based balloons-- so this
is 60,000 to 90,000 feet,
much up above where the
weather is and up above were
airplanes fly.
We were going to put thousands
of these balloons, which
you can think of like
flying cell towers.
And they would
talk to each other.
beam internet down
to cell phones, or laptops,
or whatever on the ground.
We knew we had a lot to
learn because we had not
spent-- truthfully,
almost nobody
has spent any meaningful time
hovering up in that area.
But we misestimated how
much we had to learn.
So one of the things that was
a basic part of our plan--
it's called the stratosphere
because the winds go
at different speeds and
different directions
quite close to each other.
It is stratified.
And this is a big deal for
us, a good deal for us,
because we want the balloons
to go up and down just
a little bit because it doesn't
take much energy to cause
them to go up and down.
And then they can catch winds
going in different directions
and at different speeds.
And so we can
teach the balloons.
We have taught the balloons
to sail on those winds.
What we did not
fully anticipate,
once we got up there, was, if
you have winds going like this
and winds going like
that, and your balloon is
the size of a house, when
it crosses that boundary,
it gets whipped around.
And the violence
of that process,
every time we went
through these layers
was something we
really hadn't properly
designed into the balloon.
And there was a major
redesign process
to make sure that
it was ruggedized
to survive those
particular kinds of things.
Even after that, we
were flying balloons
and our goal was to get them
to stay up for 100 days.
Our modeling of how this
could turn into a Google scale
business told us that,
on average, these things
needed to last 100
days in order for this
to be a viable business.
So at first, they
would go up, they
would explode after five
hours, and come down.
So we could learn
pretty quickly that we
were on the wrong track.
It was kind of a mess though
because, when it came down,
you didn't necessarily
knew why it blew up.
It just sort of pops.
These things are full of helium.
But after a while, once
we solved those problems,
our success became an
even bigger problem
because they would
leak really slowly.
We would wait a week.
We would wait three weeks.
Then it would start leaking.
It would take several more weeks
for it to come down in a way
where we could get
it to come down
where we could capture it, and
then go send someone to like
Southern Chile to pick it up.
This was an incredibly
inefficient way
to find out that we weren't
doing the right thing.
We needed to fail faster.
We were in the real world.
It was giving us
these signals, but we
needed to accelerate the
real world in some way.
So we created, in
this particular case,
something called a leak squad.
And their goal was to
create, detect, and then fix
the leaks that we were having.
And they studied a
lot of other things
in the world where people care
about very thin things that
don't leak.
And it's important
that they not leak.
Doritos bags, sausage
casings, condoms.
There's a lot of work that's
going on in this area.
All three of those are
important not to leak
for somewhat different reasons.
So imagine something the
size of a house rubbing soap
over it, and then, filling
it so full of helium
that somewhere the
leak would begin.
And then looking around
it for little bubbles.
Or having a wand,
about this big,
which is a helium detector.
And kind of like
a metal detector,
it would go eee if it
could smell the helium.
And then waving this
thing around this thing
the size of a house
while you've got
it overpressurized
with helium, trying
to get it to leak so
we could find the leak.
Then we could redesign how
the balloon was structured.
Or taking it, as I mentioned
before, to South Dakota.
There's like this weird polar
vortex where Santa Claus
weather had come down.
It was like minus 40,
minus 50 degrees below zero
for a couple weeks there.
And that was good
because that's actually
the temperature it is
most of the time up
in the stratosphere.
So most of the
stuff did not work.
But we did find several
really important things.
One of my favorite is that
in the manufacturing process,
the balloons are so big that we
have to stand on them in order
to make them.
And so someone brought
up the question,
I wonder if them
walking on the balloons
is what's causing
some of the weeks.
And so we did a test.
Everything's an experiment.
Failing is fine as long
as you set everything up
as an experiment
with a hypothesis.
So the hypothesis here was are
their feet making little holes?
So the control group was
them standing on the balloons
the way they were, which is
wearing their normal socks.
And then we got some
really fluffy socks.
But we need to control
the experiment.
So we actually had a line dance,
like a can can line dance.
And we had all these
manufacturing guys
on the balloon doing the line
dance in their normal socks.
And then we got another balloon.
And we had them all put
on their big fluffy socks
and do the same line dance.
And in fact, it turned
out that the balloon
with the fluffy socks
had fewer leaks in it.
It is literally at
that level that we've
had to push the real
world towards us
so we can fail quickly, so we
can discover, so we can fix it.
I really believe Loon has
made unbelievable progress.
It hasn't even been
four years yet,
and they've moved from this
crazy sounding science project
to a viable venture.
Our balloons now stay up, by the
way, for more than six months
at a time.
And we can sail them
around the world
to within 500 yards of where
we want them to go, routinely.
That they've made
that progress is
because they've been
so hungry to fail,
because they've been so hungry
to get into the real world
and to try things.
Maybe more than any other
project that we have,
the self-driving cars have
to get into the real world
in order to do their learning.
It's just the way it's wired.
And of course,
when we started, we
couldn't possibly
know the 10,000 things
that we would need to do
right in order for a car
to drive itself really well
because pretty good most
of the time is not
good enough when you
get into a self-driving car.
But we couldn't know
what that list was.
We weren't going to
sit on some white board
and write down the 10,000 weird
situations that would happen.
So you get out into
the real world.
And the truth is that the making
of that list of those 10,000
things is half of all of what's
hard about doing something
like this, like making a
self-driving car is figuring
out what the real world
wants to tell you.
So 2 and a 1/2 years ago--
this was in the fall of 2012,
we were done.
We were just done, pretty much.
We had this great
commute helper.
We had it on highways.
It was executing beautifully.
We were so done that we gave
a bunch of our Lexus vehicles,
like you can see
in this picture,
to a bunch of Googlers who
did not work at Google X.
And we said take
this home with you.
Use it for your commute.
You just drive to the
freeway, you push a button,
it'll take care of the rest.
Driving on the freeway is
actually not that hard.
You pretty much
stay in your lane.
You change lanes occasionally.
Don't hit the guy
in front of you.
Occasionally, some
bad driver makes
things a little interesting.
But basically, we
had it covered.
So we gave it to these people.
And we made them
swear that they were
going to pay 100% attention
because when we have our safety
drivers in the car, they're
like hovering like this
over the steering wheel.
The car drives for
eight hours at a time,
and they never touch
the steering wheel,
but they just have to be
like this the whole time,
so we were telling
these Googlers,
you have to do the same thing.
We're going to put
cameras in the car.
This is for your commute,
but you got to pay attention.
Yeah, oh yeah, totally.
We're going to pay so much
attention you can't believe it.
The cars, thankfully,
performed flawlessly.
The people did not.
People don't even pay
attention to driving
when they're driving.
They're like makeup, and the
texting, and the burrito.
It's horrible.
And that's when they're
actually supposed to be driving.
So imagine what they do when
they think the car's mostly
got it covered, and like
once in a blue moon,
I'm going to need to take over.
It was not pretty.
It was sufficiently not pretty
that we stopped doing it.
And we said, OK, this
is not going to work.
Humans cannot be a backup
system for the computer.
Our success was a failure when
you factored in human nature.
And so we knew that if there was
going to be a self-driving car,
it was going to have
to be something that
could go all the
way from point A
to point B by itself with
no help from the person.
This was a major existential
moment for this team.
They thought they were done.
And now all of a sudden,
they weren't just not done,
it wasn't just like
a half step back.
They were like, is
this even possible?
This is 2 and a 1/2 years ago.
The first thing was there was
like this frantic brainstorming
about how we could force
people to always pay attention
to the road because then we'd
be like fixed, like training
wheels.
And it quickly became clear
that was not the right way
to solve the problem.
So after quite a bit of
emotional process and soul
searching, the team
did what I now believe
is exactly the right thing.
They said, OK, if humans are
not a reliable backup system
for the computer,
let's build a car that
doesn't have a steering wheel.
Then, we won't be tempted
to use that as a crutch
when we hit these
parts of the process
where we don't
know how to handle.
We won't just pump that
and be like, oh, we'll
people handle that one.
So we did.
We've been doing that
for 2 and a 1/2 years.
And we just announced
recently that these cars
will start being on city
streets this summer.
Super exciting.
[APPLAUSE]
At first, they're going to
have this temporary steering
wheel in it.
And the safety driver will
just be sitting there.
But that's the right, safe thing
to do so that we can make sure
that these cars are doing
what our bigger cars have been
practicing for a long time
now, which is to always do
the right thing on these city
streets, which are much more
complicated than
being on the highway,
going all the way from
point A to point B.
There's no way we could have
learned this sort of thing
without spending a ton of
time out in the real world.
It's also a priceless
opportunity for us
to start being in
these city streets
in a more widespread way.
I think if the Lexus
vehicles that we had really,
eventually were to become the
first fully self-driving cars
on the streets, it could
provoke some anxiety in people.
And one of the things
that we're hoping
is that this car, because
it's smaller, it's cuter,
because it's only going
to go 25 miles an hour,
because we've actually
built a foam front end
and flexible windshield
in here-- I hope we never
have to use it.
But we get to experiment
with these things,
and on a bunch of
different fronts,
make sure as we're learning that
we're keeping the world super,
super safe.
So I'm excited to see this
next step for that project.
Now in order for this to really
be done-- that list of 10,000
things-- we've become-- the
self-driving car team has
become part of its own problem.
We are so good at driving
now on city streets.
We drive 10,000 miles a
week in Mountain View.
And nothing happens because the
car just does the right thing
all the time.
It is incredibly boring
for the safety drivers.
It's not very helpful
for the engineers
either because they aren't
learning much if the cars just
like, do ta do ta do.
And they're like, OK,
give it a new address.
Do ta do ta do.
We need more negative examples.
The teams at Google X are hungry
for these negative examples.
So we've created a team
on the self-driving car
team whose full time job is to
find creative ways to create
negative examples under safe
conditions for the cars.
Now one of the
ways we can do this
is just by going to new cities.
And we are starting to do this.
So for example, coming
to San Francisco,
there are interesting things
like different whether.
It's more cloudy here.
Maybe you get a little bit more
rain, probably not these days.
We're definitely not
going to get snow.
But as we move
from city to city,
we can rack up some
new experiences.
San Francisco-- one of
the interesting things
it'll give us is hills.
It's not that the cars are
going to struggle up the hill.
They can go up the hills.
But it's a reasonable question.
How will the sensors on our
cars have a hard time, or not,
when we're tilted like this
up a steep San Francisco hill.
So that's a good
thing for us to learn.
But that's still not
learning fast enough.
So this team has been trying
to find more and more ways
to challenge the cars.
And the ways in
which we have to find
these rare, weird
conditions fall into three
different categories
Situation number one is people
drive illegally.
Situation number
two is we just have
to react suddenly because
people weren't paying attention.
And then there's
just weird stuff.
The mail trucks are
jumping out in front of us.
That's the canonic
version of this.
And we have tried
thousands of examples
to simulate that jumping
out in front of us
just to try to stress our
cars on our test track.
We throw beach balls at it.
We've gone to the
Halloween store
and gotten big birds to swing
by the windshield of the car.
We've had people
hide in canvas bags
and pop out in the
middle of the road
just to see what
the car would do.
On take your children to
work day, we parked the cars,
but had the sensors running just
so the kids would play around
them, so we could
get the computer
used to watching kids move so
we could learn how they move.
And the reason that we
could do the following
is because we did all that.
A few months ago, we were coming
down a suburban side street.
The car turned a corner and
came automatically to a stop.
There was a woman,
an elderly woman
in an electric wheelchair,
holding a broom,
in the middle of the road,
trying to shoo a duck out
of the middle of the road.
And they were going
around in little circles
in the middle of the road.
I'm sure this was
shocking to the car
as well as well as to
the safety drivers.
But eventually, she got
the duck out of the road,
she moved off the street, and
the car continued autonomously.
That it stopped autonomously
and started autonomously again,
and there was no problem, is
thanks to these field tests
that we're doing.
Getting out and getting into
contact with the real world
is the most valuable thing
you can do for your project.
All of our audacious
yearly and quarterly goals
have this characteristic
of what are
we going to build, how
are we going to test it
in the real world, and how are
those tests designed to reveal
as fast as possible the
unanticipated design
flaws with what we're building.
I really believe
that the progress
of Google X has made
over the last five years
comes from our excitement
and throwing ourselves
at the world, of
pursuing these projects
with the maniacal
focus of a startup,
and then the being
hungry to be wrong,
being hungry to make
mistakes, to get
these negative experiences
and then harness them
to do it better the next time.
I know it sounds like a weird
thing to be excited about,
but I think it's
our special sauce.
I've always wanted Google X not
just to take its own moonshots,
but to encourage other
people to think this way,
to take on some of
these problems, too.
So even if you're not working
on a self-driving car,
I hope you can take something
away from this approach
and set yourself up for
creative, productive, mistake
filled contact with
the real world.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm happy to take a few
questions if you like.
There are microphones here.
AUDIENCE: Is that working?
ASTRO TELLER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: There we go.
So looking at a product
at a typically development
IT organization and
balancing innovation
from product management.
So from a company
who's typically
focused on building
the next product,
pounding the sales team lines,
building, building, building,
do you have any suggestions
or recommendations of how
to actually put
engineering culture first
on top of that innovation.
Is it just a matter of saying,
OK, let's put you guys aside.
Let's insulate you.
Is there an insulation
process in that,
inside of the heavily
driven, product management,
sales driven company?
ASTRO TELLER: I'm not sure
this is the answer you want.
It's a weird thing to say
at a developers conference.
I don't think an engineering
heavy approach is
any better than a sales
heavy driven approach.
I think any company
that is overweighted
on any of these things
is missing the point.
When we look to fail
in the real world,
we depend equally on
finance, on product managers,
on designers and UX
people, on engineers.
Anyone who can find a reason
why we're on the wrong track
is going to be the super
hero of the month for us.
And so I guess
what I would say is
rather than trying to
isolate engineering
from these pressures,
what I would try to do
is evangelize to them
that they're missing
half of their opportunities.
And that if they think
about it as discovering
as fast as possible why
what we're currently doing
isn't the right thing to do,
that's the most efficient way
to make progress.
And cutting off some
of the reasons why it
might be a bad reason.
If you know that it
breaks the law of physics
and you're not allowed to say
so, your company is broken
and it's wasting its money.
And surely like the sales people
are like, yeah, that's true.
Then you can say, then,
invite me to the meetings.
Yeah
AUDIENCE: I just had a question
about the self-driving car.
I think there was a quote
from Elon Musk or something.
He was saying sort of
what you said, right?
Freeway speeds are easy.
0 to 35 range is easy.
But it's that 35, to
say, 55 mile an hour
zone where you can't
simply stop, right?
And a lot of crazy
things can happen.
So I guess I'm just
curious to hear
what the testing you
do in that range is
and what your experiences are.
ASTRO TELLER: Look none
of it's easy, to be fair.
The highways are very
constrained situations.
There are some
oddities that happen,
but a microscopic
fraction of the oddities
that happen on city streets.
So that's partly about speed.
Part of the issue,
which is some of what
Elon is getting at there is
that the energy of the car, m v
squared.
When you double the velocity
of the car, you get four times
the energy, four times
the braking distance,
it does complicate things
when you're going faster.
Our experience has been
with that going slower
will help from a
safety perspective.
That's part of why we're
focused on 25 miles an hour
and under for the moment.
But what I would highlight
is the really hard bits
of this are the duck.
When someone walks out into
the street holding a stop sign,
like a crossing guard,
that's a legal stop sign.
The car has to figure that out.
Figuring out the 10,000
things like that.
When a bike is
coming the wrong way
down a bike lane, which should
dominate in the computer's way
of approaching that problem?
The fact that they should
be going that way, and bikes
tend to be going that way,
or the physical reality
that its momentum is this way.
Those 10,000 things--
my experience--
are the really hard things.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How would
you characterize
Google X's experience
when bringing Google Glass
into the real world?
ASTRO TELLER: So I've
said this before.
So first of all,
Google Glass, I think,
is making really good progress.
It's graduated from Google X
to Tony Fidel's part of Google.
And we will be hearing more
in the future about that.
But I think we did something
right and something wrong.
The thing that we did right,
that I would absolutely
do again, is getting it out into
the world, and in some ways,
even in the way we got
it out into the world.
The Explorer Program was
exactly the right thing to do,
and we owe a ton to Explorers.
Thank you, if
you're one of them.
But we were trying to learn
also about the social issues
around Glass.
And there were ways in which
by trying to figure out
how people would
think about Glass,
we ended up sending signals
that it wasn't a prototype,
that it was a finished product.
Things like putting
it on a runway.
I mean, even that was not
crazy as an experiment
to see how people would think
about it and respond to it.
But it did leave
people with the feeling
that it was a
finished product when
we weren't productizing it yet.
We were just trying to learn.
And I think we left people with
some confusing messages there.
And that I wish we
had done differently.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: How do you think
about financial resourcing
each of these products?
Almost by definition,
a moonshot,
these could have infinite,
or almost infinite,
financial resources.
So how do you decide
which products
are going to get a
dollar or which one's
going to get a billion dollars?
ASTRO TELLER: I'm
not sure I agree
that you need near infinite
resources for these things.
That's true only if
you're too shy to say
for long periods
of time that you're
working on the wrong thing.
It's amazing how in
every project when you're
doing something dumb, when it's
going in the wrong direction,
I guarantee you 20% or more of
the team knows it within weeks.
You guys are engineers.
You know what I'm
talking about, right?
You know, and no one
will listen to you.
What if you lived in a culture
where people are like, really.
Well, let's stop then.
It's unbelievable how much money
you can save when you do that.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
But just to answer the
rest of your question,
it is also the case that as
long as we start on a moonshot
and we believe that there's
a good return on investment
over some very long period of
time, where a reward to risk
ratio is good for Google, then
as we go through the process,
if you're building
this moonshot for us,
I'm going to have a dialogue
with you about how much
resources have I given
you and how much have
you do derisked the project.
And as long as the
risks are coming
down faster than I'm
giving you money,
our ROI is actually
getting better.
And as long as
that's true, I'm just
going to keep handing
you the resources.
And if we go the
other way, where
I'm giving you more
resources and it's not
getting any less risky,
then probably the resources
shouldn't keep coming.
I think I have time
for one or two more.
AUDIENCE: Specifically
about the self-driving cars,
could you talk about
the 11 accidents
that the cars have been
involved in over the past year
or so, both how they happened
and what you've learned
from them going forward.
ASTRO TELLER: So there
are certain things
that I'm not even
allowed to get into.
There's legal issues around it.
I don't mean at Google.
I mean the DMV and
things like that.
But what we've said publicly,
and I encourage everyone here,
if you're interested,
to go look at the blog
that we post that we put out
about this is 7 of those 11,
we were parked.
I mean not parked on the
side, we were stationary.
So the car wasn't driving.
The human wasn't driving either.
We were just rear ended.
I don't know what we
could do about that.
That's just going
to keep happening.
We should expect that to
happen at roughly the rate it's
been happening to us
because we can't not
have a back end to the car.
The other four, the
person was driving.
Our safety drivers
are pretty miraculous.
And they have a much better
record than me or you guys do.
But I'm sure we could
improve that in some ways.
We have yet to have the
car be driving itself
when any of these have happened.
So I don't have more to
report to you on that.
But I guess that's good news.
But we plan to continue to do
these blog posts like we've
been doing them to help people
understand what we're learning
and how we can improve.
All right.
Last question.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
about you personally.
ASTRO TELLER: I'll get you too.
AUDIENCE: You do
a lot of projects.
You manage a lot of projects.
You speak a lot.
And like I've always
seen you at your 100%.
So what are some
things that we can
do that you do to switch
contexts between projects
while remaining efficient.
ASTRO TELLER: I'm not a maker.
I mean, I used to be a maker.
I have a PhD in
computer science.
But to be fair, I'm good
at context switching.
Makers, the people who are
actually building the stuff,
do not context switch at the
speed that I context switch.
So there's obviously
a much longer thing.
Maybe I'll do a op-ed
on it or something.
I think it's an
interesting question.
But my short answer is hold
yourself to the energy level
that you aspire to, but don't
necessarily hold yourself
to the context
switching level that I
do because that's not always the
way to be the most productive.
AUDIENCE: I'm an
engineer at Salesforce.
So I was wondering, I
always had this attitude
where I go to the
different departments.
I go to the strange people
in the different departments
to get some code,
to just tell me
how they did some things so I'm
not writing this from scratch.
And I'm talking to the
people from the boss,
like what they think.
I have these strange things.
And it's very beneficial.
I found this progressing faster.
I'm just curious from
the people around me,
I didn't see a lot
of such people.
And do you think from your
experience, it comes naturally
or like you can teach
or motivate someone
to do this because a lot
of people are just shy.
ASTRO TELLER: I
understand the question.
I believe everyone here
is a moonshot thinker,
in your hearts.
I promise you, I would not
be giving this talk this way
if I did not believe that.
I believe that
most of us are not
in a context where we can be
as open minded, as honest,
as dispassionate
when appropriate,
as authentic as we want to be,
as our natural selves would be.
And I think you need to ask your
context for that opportunity.
And if it's really not going
to give it to you, be humble,
try a few times.
And if it doesn't work,
go find a new context.
You all deserve to be
able to let the best
part of your selves out.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]